[Music]
it was a big strong boy with a very big
heart everyone loved and knew him I just
Leslie broken insight about everything
hurts
tonight we saw we won't just suggest
this us all he was any noisy impressive
just doing what he loved
doesn't doesn't meet family in ruin
we're broken we can't grieve can't just
leave she's got to come back and and
face the consequences I don't need any
mom or dad could this all we just just
just suggested soon
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it was big-hearted generous its
free-spirited fun-loving that loves my
money would do anything for anybody
worked really hard to fund his passion
for rising it was barely a day you went
party where he didn't go out riding on
his bike there is the man himself
he just was the most beautiful boy just
a beautiful boy 19 year old Harry Dunn
had been on his motorbike on his way to
see his dad it was a summer evening
August the 27th he was riding through
the village of Croton in
Northamptonshire Pennings believe he was
traveling on the right side of the road
he would have been approaching the brow
of that hill when he was hit head-on by
a woman driving in the wrong direction
he was taken to hospital but he later
died of multiple injuries
the crash site was just outside RAF
Croton when the ambulances arrived
Harry was still alive unfortunately four
hundred five hundred yards down the road
Harry was the first thing to meet sir
and he just didn't didn't have a chance
his bike against a big 4x4 Volvo he just
brought into the screen and he was into
the verge the driver of the other
vehicle is 42 year old and cyclist she's
the wife of US diplomat Jonathan sakulos
who was stationed at RAF Croton an
American spy base
mrs. sakulos a mother of three claimed
diplomatic immunity and left the country
we don't know when she went we have met
with the suspect and the presence of
legal advisors in order for us to
identify the best way forward during the
course of that meeting we were aware
that diplomatic immunity had been raised
as an issue and we then made a major
application for a waiver in order for us
to undertake further investigations and
interview unfortunately we were
laterally advised that the waiver had
been declined and that the suspect had
left the UK
three weeks after the crash a motorcycle
hearse led Harry's funeral procession
[Music]
dozens of bikers followed some he knew
some he didn't
[Music]
police waited until after Harry's
funeral to tell his parents that
diplomatic immunity would not be waived
and that answer coulis had gone from the
USA and kill somebody and be allowed to
go be allowed to flee to the family it's
friends everyone loved and knew him and
we don't know how on earth we can start
to grieve for him because nothing we
have no justice we have we have no
nothing to put on what is at rest that
she's even remorseful we've had nothing
we've had no contact a letter arrived
two days after the funeral it was from
the US ambassador to the UK offering his
condolences I think the only thing that
really sparked that letter if if I'm
honest is the fact that we who formed
the UK police that Harry's stepdad
stroke second dad and my husband we
informed the UK police the either US
citizen and within 48 hours of that news
reaching the embassy we received that
letter from the Ambassador but that is
this was the first contact and that was
two and a half weeks after we'd lost
Harry which to us at the moment still
only feels like two days ago since we
lost him because which is stuck we're
stuck with nothing something's with this
board it's wrong it's wrong and bless
Harry he was just hiding his boy
now carrying a well just riding this
bike along the road and he just just
like that and then now there's nothing
we can do this lady has fled the scene
and we're left with nothing
we lost our son and we have no no way of
getting justice or any ounces or
anything
we made every effort to contact answer
coolest but she didn't respond and soon
afterwards most traitors have her online
disappeared we also went to her original
address in America but she hadn't gone
back to it
in the suburbs near Reston Virginia
around 40 minutes from Washington and
sakulos house is being rented out
neighbors described her as a kind loving
mother who'd recently moved to England I
understand just leave she's got to come
back and and face the consequences if it
was me if it was me I couldn't have left
any mom or dad could the family felt
that they had no official help so they
turned to a neighbor a former lawyer and
now their spokesperson this family is
incredible
they're dignified they're magnanimous
they don't hate this woman they know she
made a mistake what they're struggling
to forgive is the running away overnight
really what what we want is closure
carrying anger and hatred and it's just
gonna be more and more painful so we we
started discussing the possibility of
how could we build a bridge between two
families that are clearly devastated we
consider her a victim as well as I said
we've been appealing to them to come and
talk to us for many many weeks now and
it's nothing happening so I fear that
the opportunity to do that now if it's
not lost that it's nearly lost
answer coulis did not respond but the
Prime Minister Boris Johnson did I do
not think that it can be right to use
the process of diplomatic immunity
for this type of purpose and I hope that
answer coulis will come back and will
engage properly with the processes of
laws they're carried out in this country
and that's a point that we've raised or
are raising today with the the American
ambassador here in in the UK and I hope
it will be resolved very shortly and you
know to anticipate a question you might
want to raise if we can't resolve it
then of course I will be raising it
myself personally with the White House
after the break the diplomatic fallout
the woman was driving on the wrong side
of the road and and that can happen you
know those are the opposite roads that
happens I won't say it ever happened to
me but it did
what started as a tragic yet seemingly
straightforward accident investigation
has escalated to an international
incident do you think it's right in this
case that that she's been able to claim
immunity that's really one for the
foreign commonwealth office who've done
a really good job here but actually if
you look at what what it looks like the
proper use of immunity it was originally
designed for diplomats to be working in
hostile environments that's clearly not
the case here in the United Kingdom and
I think actually if you kind of go back
in our recent history there actually
hasn't been a situation in in and this
is unique in there actually they've used
diplomatic immunity in this way
the Foreign Secretary asked the u.s. to
reconsider waiving diplomatic immunity
and offered to meet the family Harry's
parents have new partners who have
always been known as Harry's second mum
and dad they are united in their fight
for justice for Harry his twin brother
Niall and the rest of their large family
on their journey to meet the foreign
secretary they passed the crash site
it's just where the flowers are still
there look oh my lord the stills
RAF Croton is just a few miles from
their home Sky News understands that
there is a special agreement for the
base to allow American spies to operate
on British soil without fear of
prosecution in 2013 it was reported that
the station had played a part in the
hacking of German Chancellor Angela
Merkel's phones by US intelligence
agencies so an ordinary family find
themselves in an extraordinary situation
hopeful really hopeful but I don't want
to get my hopes up too much in case it's
not what we want
I hope I'm wrong but I think they're
gonna try and get away with yeah I'll
tell you I'm sorry I still do I'm hoping
that I'm hoping he's going to tell me
it's good new she's coming back and
everything
they entered the Foreign and
Commonwealth Office looking for action
they came out with nothing new just
disgusted let down by both governments
and really see the point as to why we
were invited to go and see dominic rob
we are no further forward than when we
were this time last week the family said
that Dominic Rob reiterated that the
prime minister would phone president
Trump they began their journey home with
little hope everybody else in the world
can see what she's done is wrong why
can't they see that I feel like I'm
being an idiot because I could see it we
could all see it well we can't the two
most powerful men in the whatever why
can't they see it seriously
they travel the 70 miles home planning
their next legal steps to get justice
for their son
Scully News understands that someone
from the u.s. embassy told answer
coolest to leave they said that as a
diplomat's wife she was entitled to
immunity
the Americans maintain that it is rarely
waived but in 1997 the US was on the
other side of the debate when Georgian
diplomat Aoki Makarov ski killed 16
year-old jovian Warrick and injured four
others while drink-driving in Washington
there was a public outcry led by Jovians
parents and the Clinton administration
pressured Georgia to waive his
diplomatic immunity which they did he
spent five years in prison but it's 35
years since a country stood firm against
the UK over diplomatic immunity
after the killing of Metropolitan Police
Officer Yvonne Fletcher in London in
1984 she was shot dead by someone from
the window of the Libyan embassy when
the 11 day siege ended all those inside
including the killer made their way out
and flew home after being granted
diplomatic immunity the main suspect is
still being pursued in a civil case and
that is something Harry's family will
consider if answer coulis won't come
back
we hope that wiser political minds will
prevail and mrs. su colas will be
delivered back to stand trial and to
give an account of herself but if that
fails to happen it is worth remembering
that diplomatic immunity only applies
whilst you're in the foreign state and
now she's returned to the United States
the family are entitled to sue her now
this isn't about money this is about
them understanding an explanation of how
she came to kill their son and I think
the British government if they're going
to not report repatriate her should
actually be funding the family to sue in
America so they can get the explanation
which they so richly deserve Harry's
case was raised in a phone call to
President Trump by the Prime Minister
it's the only thing we've got it's the
only thing we've got left
just that grain of hope that yet Donald
Trump can give us because he has the
power to do that isn't it he's the only
one I think from what we understand from
what we would assume and he's the only
one that could give us what we need as a
as a family to be able to start trying
to cover ourselves and his twin and
their siblings but if we don't get it
we will pursue we have I was telling
Boris we have a lot of Americans that
you know they side on on the fact that
you know you have two wonderful parents
that lost their son and the woman was
driving on the wrong side of the road
and and that can happen you know those
are the opposite roads that happens I
won't say it ever happened to me but it
did when you get used to driving on our
system and then you're all of a sudden
in the other system where you're driving
it happens have to be careful very
careful so young man was killed the
person that was driving the automobile
has diplomatic immunity we're going to
speak to her very shortly and see if we
can do something where they meet it was
an accident it was an act it was a
terrible accident we're going to speak
to her and we're going to see the person
driving the car the wife of the diplomat
we're going to speak to her and see what
we can come up with so that they can be
some healing this tremendous anger over
it it's a terrible incident this
tremendous anger and I understand the
anger from the other side
photographer zoomed in on the
president's notes as he put them away
had he been asked he would confirm that
answer Kulas would not return to the UK
and that she would need to consider
based on the advice of her legal counsel
whether to make herself available for
questioning by the British authorities
in my experience America is very very
reluctant to allow its nationals to be
tried overseas and he's absolutely
ruthless in enforcing the code of
diplomatic immunity I must say I don't
think it was appropriate for that
provision to be used in this case and I
made that point to the president
although Donald Trump says that many
people have done it yes I'm not denying
I'm sure they have but
most people realize through one thing or
another before they hit somebody that
that's what they're doing
what distractions that she had in the
car was she on her phone we still don't
have her phone records there are still
those questions we still haven't had
answered to us is a case that is so easy
an accident prongs like the road
everything proves it CCTV proves it why
is it taking this long to get these
people to agree this and just do the
right thing I don't I know they're
talking and I know things are moving on
but it just seems to be I can't
understand what the conversations can be
I know there's bigger things but it's
quite simple it really is six weeks
after the crash there is subtle
acknowledgment of what went wrong here
but for the family supporters it is
nowhere near enough and they say that
the sense of injustice is growing
[Applause]
the community that surrounds the airbase
are coming together to reflect this
and to raise money for Harry's family
who are going to America
the diplomacy may be complicated but for
many it is a simple case of doing what's
right they have no idea whether answer
coulis and her government are listening
you know we've got so many pieces of the
jigsaw puzzle missing and the truth we
just need to the truth is the most
important truth from it we're going to
keep trying to find it we will keep
digging and use every source we possibly
can to keep digging and getting to the
truth from start to finish
[Music]